[Music]
it's taken almost six months to get this
far and today it's make-or-break for the
bad boys bakery I'm so nervous I mean
it's just like first day at school
go show something really exciting the
time honey I'm so happy to be here sure
so these are made in literary and Kevin
arrow have taken in 11 stores which is
fantastic I persuaded neros to put the
slices right next to the tail just
launched a boy bakery lemon tart treacle
sliced and made in Brixton prison is
about the ethics of them seven per
sentence and actually grafting which
makes you feel a little bit sort of
affect on the outside would you yeah
thank you so much the idea was just
getting them working on the inside we do
something for the outside
don't be narrow be brilliant they're
gonna showcase it for a week I've got a
lovely sauce so we're putting in this
morning over 1100 lemon tickle slices
which is great news
at the next branch I've arranged to meet
a familiar face and natural salesman you
great white rhinos
what's it like me now
Anthony's dishing out the bad boys
bakery message box gran woody gonna cut
them up and going out and cook one of
these and a three-course meal but it all
started nice tell me I wouldn't get that
opportunity without doing this has our
catchphrase life-changing taste made the
right impact give him new focus in life
on here there's one here which I've got
from NASA 23 things has changed his life
[Music]
the customers like it but unless the man
from Nero's is impressed the slice won't
be on sale next week we have a chat
about next steps where we go from here
of course all right it's a great product
if it proves to be as good as I think
it's gonna be yeah we want it
consistency is a next big issue you know
day in day out you've got to be
consistently good the operations in a
bakery are gonna have to be adapted you
might have to get some new machinery you
know bigger mixers whatever so the onus
goes on to you to be able to show that
you can scale this up for us yeah I
suppose the positive is great good
product great concept now we're gonna
make it work
the slice has been an immediate hit
[Music]
and neighbors have agreed to keep on
sale until further notice Oh sweetheart
great news I mean really positive which
is the best that we could ever hope for
oh yes
[Music]
during my six months banged up in
Brixton I've managed to get prisoners
out of their cells and working we've got
the production kitchen up and running
and a prison made product that the
public love okay yes
right good news look brilliant honestly
to see it sat on the Shelf to be enjoyed
they loved it yeah the message is you
should feel incredibly proud to see them
here's the bad news
yeah start again yeah yeah well done
well done well done
I seriously well done my time in Brixton
is almost up but cafe Nero want to keep
selling the slice in the end this bakery
has got to start paying his own way but
to keep open now I'm going to ask for
temporary funding from the Ministry of
Justice everything we've done over the
last six months we can't do anymore
unless someone takes this and runs with
it in a week's time this place is closed
these guys are back in their cell and
that product disappears